the switch to daylight saving time may
have caused you an hour of sleep over
the wig weekend yes it did but new
research shows most of us were already
behind on our rest the National Sleep
Foundation released the data as part of
its sleep Awareness Week which is this
week it shows just 27 percent of US
adults get the recommended 7 to 9 hours
of sleep during the week only 10 percent
prioritize sleep over other daily
activities entrepreneur Arianna
Huffington says a lack of sleep
compromised her own health and
productivity she used that experience to
create thrive global a company focused
on helping people put their personal
well-being first Arianna Huffington
joins us now good morning Arianna good
morning how are you so you've been on
this crusade to help people stop being I
think it's cool to not get much sleep
how's that going
well actually it's going really well
despite the latest results that gave
mentioned because when I collapsed from
sleep deprivation exhaustion broke my
cheekbone and launched a sleep section
and on The Huffington Post people who
are wondering why sleep who cares about
sleeps successful people don't need
sleep now all that is changing and
you're just as likely to read about
sleep in the sports pages because
athletes talk about the connection
between sleep and performance are in the
business pages and on tribe club or on a
media platform we have all what we call
new role models Jeff Bezos writing about
why he gets 8 hour sleep because it
improves his decision-making or Eric
Schmidt or Satya Nadella the CEO of
Microsoft so it's not becoming cool to
talk about getting enough sleep it shows
you are prioritizing your performance
and the old role models were the CEOs
who are sending emails at all hours in
the night and there's actually in the
National Survey it says 30 percent of
employed adults think sending late-night
emails show that they care more so that
has to change too
yes well everything is changing sleep is
just one part but the whole connection
between well-being and performance is
changing people now realize that there
is no trade off between them that on the
contrary when we take care of ourselves
when as we say on thrive we put around
oxygen mask
then everything else is better you know
empathy increases our decision-making
improves we are not as reactive and as a
result every aspect of our lives
improves I know the difference that it
makes I just wish I could figure out how
to do it but before you collapsed did
you think that you were getting enough
sleep was it a bit I know it was a big
wake-up call for you but did you think
that you were really doing okay
yes that's such a good question gay
because we take now better care of our
smartphones so we know exactly how much
battery remains on a smartphone but if
you had asked me the morning I collapsed
Ariana how are you would have said fine
because being perpetually tired had
become the new normal and in fact our
relationship with technology you
mentioned that in the intro John is so
key to why so many people have trouble
sleeping we are becoming more and more
addicted to our phones and people have
forgotten that we need a transition to
sleep so we have a series of micro steps
on thrive to help people and can I
mention my two favorite micro steps one
is picking a time at the end of the day
when you turn off your phone and gently
escort them out of your bedroom gently
escort them so basically you should no
longer be sleeping with your phones and
get 70% of people sleep with their
phones and it's not just the blue light
it's the fact that our phone is the
repository of every problem every
project and we need to disconnect from
that to be able to surrender to that
chip one tip to tip to is how you wake
up most people wake up and the first
thing they do before they take their
first fully conscious breath yeah it's
go to the phone yeah and all
neuroscience tells you that even if you
take one minute literally one minute to
set your intention for the day remember
what you are grateful for what you are
looking forward to it changes the tone
of the day well that's setting your
intention what you're grateful being
mindful essentially is the way to step
back from all of this exactly and put
things in perspective and people have
endless excuses like I need my phone as
my alarm clock you can buy a very
beautiful one from Pottery Barn for $35
you know basically create a system that
supports you having this small little
transitions at night and in the morning
all right
Arianna Huffington is always good to
have you thank you